hello and welcome to the android
application development course offered
by simply learn
in this course we will learn how to
develop android applications and use
different controls we will also see how
to publish your own application in
google play having basic knowledge of
java would be an added advantage for
this course on completing this course
successfully you will be able to develop
and publish an android application on
your own let us start with chapter one
introduction to android application
development by understanding the
objectives
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to explain the architecture of
android operating system list the
components of android application
describe the activity and life cycle of
activity explain stack of activity
explain service its use and importance
we will also discuss what broadcast
receiver is and why it is used we